et booba bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation dans la matinale de rtl
france alors le président ma qui est
donc sortir de son silence hier pour
appeler au calme et à la sérénité avec
quelques heures plus tôt son principal
opposant ousman sonko a été relâchée
est-ce que cela devrait permettre
d'apaiser les tensions dans les heures
ou les jours qui viennent à mon avis je
crois que cela mettra effectivement un
peu de retenu l'attention
vous savez très bien que le car son
propre camp le plus c'est à dire que ça
a permis à ce cocktail qui était déjà
qui était déjà un art et que les
sénégalais vivent est donc pleinement
s'il y en a certainement donné un
effectif pas je crois que la sorte qu'il
était bon de sortie et que les
sénégalais donc cela a brisé les scellés
gagner mais il faudra aussi aujourd'hui
le sénégal
ils retiennent ils attendent encore les
prisonniers politiques qui sont des
zones qui ont été libérés puisque il ya
des gemmes aussi qui se sont regroupés
qui sont sortis pour dire non à ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui au sénégal n'ont
peut-être pas que tout cela a été fait
avant de revenir sur la situation plus
générale peut-être arrêtons-nous sur l'
affaire qui concerne ousman sonko
on le disait il a été relâché hier sous
contrôle judiciaire
c'était un son arrestation qui avait
déclenché des émeutes
ils avaient été arrêtés dans des dans
une affaire de viol présumé lui il crie
au complot l'empêcherait de se présenter
aux présidentielles de 2024 qu'est ce
qu'il en est selon vous clairement qu
est-ce que vous pouvez nous démêler le
spider man mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il faudra je crois que dans
toutes les justices mort de celui qui
est joli pied ou celui qui est inculpé
par deux podiums pour une liberté
conditionnelle
on le voit aujourd'hui sellal ici bonsu
a vu la situation du pays
c'est sûr qu'il fallait faire quelque
chose des gens puissent rentrer chez eux
tranquillement et baquet à autre chose
je sais c'est qu'il faudra monter mais
l'essentiel est que la paix puisse
revenir ce qui s'est passé avec soin de
sa peau et a dit ça je ne peux rien dire
a dit ça a donné sa version au choco à
donner sa version
mais si vous mangez prend effectivement
dans le passé ce qui fait citer brûlé la
langue le prix d'or aujourd'hui c'est ce
que nous avons vu dans le passé présente
les acteurs politiques ont été mis en
prison
sa dernière tout cela dans le challenge
plutôt dans la vision du gouvernement
actuel nous avons vu donc m nota le
casal khalifa sall qui a été a été mis
en prison l'auteur à travers qui
aujourd'hui ne peut pas jouer de tous
ses droits pour pouvoir être éligible
nous avons vu d'autres ce n'est pas à
moi de le fils est allé moi qui est dans
la même situation aujourd'hui donc dans
lé là nous avons vu que son co a été
aussi donc sur cette lancée là enfin
nous leurrons pas ce que le public avait
soutenu comme thèse qu'il allait
éliminer dans tous ses opposants se sont
jamais des effectivement donc ça la fois
les applis dont l'association qui sait
ce qui peut venir au sénégal ce décor
que nous voyons et tonnes de bore qui a
été a été créée de toute petite pièce ça
c'est donc les choix de la population
sénégalaise est ce que derrière la faire
son coup il n'ya pas aussi un prétexte
pour dénoncer la précarité de la
population active la précarité je
faisais de tout à l'heure quand c'est
trop c'est encore talent à la population
aujourd'hui une caricature a dénaturé
ils sont frappés par la mélancolie la
détresse la sphère l'injustice en plus
effectivement le cas son corps est de
trop et donc il fallait que lcd qu'elle
n'aime pas l'injustice et cela le pays
sera en salles ne savez même été victime
lorsqu'il est dans le camp lorsqu'il
était avec le paysage de la loi il a
subit donc le même sens et il a vu que
tout le sénégal était là à son associé
et tout le monde l'a soutenu je vois que
c'est des choses qui sont tout à fait
dans l'adn sénégalais dans la culture
sénégalaise le sénégalais n'est pas la
justice
et voilà ce sont les résultats est ce
qu'il faudra aussi souligné c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un problème pour un
grand final qui doit être traité avec
une certaine acuité
c'est surtout donc 2024 il faudrait que
le présent de la vie sénégal freestyle
clairement à la population sénégalaise
puissance et représentera pas en 2004
est en 2025
c'est bien mais 24 sera son dernier
mandat sinon ce mouvement sera toujours
là et j'en suis persuadé que ça sera
effectivement l'objectif final sont
mobilisés se mobiliser pour qu'il n'y
ait jamais un troisième mandat au
sénégal parce qu'aujourd'hui plus de
passes que le président sales doit
éclaircir cette situation là cette
population alors il ya également on l'a
vu le sentiment anti-français qui
commence à nourrir les débats
qu'est ce qui engendre ce sentiment
comment l'expliquer écoutez le problème
anti français je ne crois pas tellement
donc vous savez quand il ya des tas
c'est vrai qu'il ya des cas ce bon voilà
je suis ça va se faire casser oui il ya
eu beaucoup de casse et ça vous savez on
peut pas contrôler on peut pas dire
aussi que les sénégalais sont
artificiels personnellement je n'y crois
pas mais peut-être seulement aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que la france essayait de
revoir sa copie de voir sa relation qui
les attend d'être passé effectivement
avec avec la chaux la france et le
sénégal qui se tient par l'histoire
donc c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
quelque chose d'un peu de gens lui
maintenant voir les gens s'attaquent t
on bien français voilà ce n'est pas
parce que c'est là où il ya la logique
parce que c'est là où il ya des choses
des gens prennent ce service n'est pas
que moi je le vois je ne vois pas que
ces maisons françaises non non non au
sénégal de france est inégale et ils
sont prêts dans la société sénégalaise
dont je crois qu'il faut merci beaucoup
il vous pas d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans la matinale de pertes et
franc je le rappelle vous êtes
journaliste politique sénégalais